Great, now we have the theory out of the way, let's jump into the engine and have a look
at some of these examples.
Now the first way of making a material interactive, this actually isn't going to
require us to do any coding at all, except for within the material itself.
Now let me demonstrate this to start off with.
I'm coming up to example six here, camera distance. If I was to just press play,
now you would see here we have a bridge, a bridge which appears as the character moves across it.
You can see here, we've got the bridge, you can see that as we get closer the bridge just moves
into place, giving us this nice dynamic effect. Another example of the same sort of
functionality working in the same way would be this door here. As I get close, the door opens,
and as I get far away the door closes. Now this can be done in a number of different ways,
but what I'm using here, and I'll jump into the material, so what you can see here is I'm using
primarily the world position offset. The only other thing I've got, I've got nothing else plugged in
here really. I played around with the base color and a couple other odds and sorts, but the world
position offset is the only thing that I'm really using. Now I am lerping between the A,
so you must have come across a lerp by now, but what a lerp will do is, depending on the alpha,
if the value that comes into the alpha is either going to provide the value from A,
if the alpha is zero, if the alpha is one, it will provide the value from B,
and if the alpha is 0.5 it will provide halfway between these two values.
So you can see what I'm doing here. World position offset. This allows me to move
the vertices. If it's 0 and 1, it's going to be in its original position. However, if the value
is at B, it's going to create a location far away. I've got a couple of rather more clever
things I'm doing here. For example, I'm using the world position to generate a random value,
meaning that each of the instances will have a different value, so they'll all move to a
different location. I'm adding some random rotation, and I'm using the sine wave to make
this this bob up and down. Now what I'm doing here is this is plugging into the alpha,
but I am looking at the distance between the object position and the camera position,
getting the distance. I'm doing a little bit of maths and clamping it to 0 to 1 so it doesn't
go over or under the values. And so as the camera gets closer to the object's position,
it's going to provide us a different value between 0 and 1, and that's what will allow
us to look. And so you can see here as I move further away in the viewport,
it moves off to a random location. So this is the sort of simplest example of it. We have
all we've done in this large section is generated a bobbing up and down random location,
and then based off the distance of the camera, we are moving between those two points. Now
we're effectively doing the same thing with the door, but it's a little bit more complicated.
Do feel free to check out the material here in order to see how that works.